foreign
counting problem but in some sense it
kind of further away from the theme of
the workshop but I'm sorry for that I I
hope you still find it interesting
somehow
okay here is that
foreign
first I will introduce counting problem
as generally did that for in the
previous talk so I have a easy job here
but I do where I introduce A New
Perspective of counting problem which
relates a probability distribution over
instance of accounting problem then I
will demonstrate our main approach of
this of this new design Technique we are
the most simplest uh kind of constraint
system which is the two states spin
system basically this is a local
constraint system where each
Constitution is a binary Constitution
involves two variables and each variable
takes value from a Boolean to mess so
it's a kind of very simple case then I
will briefly mention some more
results and extensions for the much more
complexes like the multi multi-speed
system and multiply system
okay so counting problem
so the stat is a one of the most
canonical examples of computational
problem which given a CM formula ask is
there a system assignment or not this is
the student problem and the counting
version actually count how many
satisfying assignments of a single
formula so similarly we can count as
many other properties like the color
link of the class like independent set
of graph like contains the perfect
matching of a better graph which is a
permit of the adjacent measures so and
so on and so forth so these are all
really natural and interesting
computational problem but some of you
may still ask why do we care about the
number of solutions for for consuming
problem so here I would like to list
more problems which may not look like
accounting problem at first but still
indeed is
one the first example is the probability
probability is actually indeed
accounting problem which counts the
number of samples in a cyber space where
a random event happened so this is
basically accounting problem if you if
you have a better argument to do that
you can make a bad decision and even
bring money and the second example is
the partition function in statistic
physics which is indeed a weighted
accounting and statistics physics
partition function is a very important
quantity to describe the physics system
and which encode many other information
like the entropy energy of the system
and so on so first so the example is
that like in machine learning Fields as
a model called classic Model and there's
one important task of graphic models
influence basically compute the marginal
probability of some variables and maybe
condition on some observations and these
are actually a counting problem
and many other problem like the
qualities on the probabilistic database
or some optimization problem for
stochastic models and so forth so
for the exactly counting framework and
actually from the dichotomy you will see
that for most of the case the problem is
shall be hard as you say for the for the
checkable case that it's not full length
it's kind of a major zero thing so most
of the problem is actually sharply hard
so
we can say we would like to further
classify the sharp highness problem in
terms of the approximation so we want to
show that a certain uh certain problem
is approximately and some other problem
is still hard even you allow
approximation so let's define more
precisely what do we mean by approximate
counting so being approximation
parameter and Z be the correct counting
number of instance so the algorithm
which is called Z Prime which is within
a relative
from the collected value and in time
portfolio and one optional so this is
called uh epsiliters
scheme for the problem and another uh a
random marginalization for that's called
FC loss
come on okay any questions
so
uh to the end of this approximate
content I would like to introduce A New
Perspective of County plug Group which
relates a probabilistic distribution
over accounting problem so let's use a
one concrete example like the
independent set problem or graph so here
let's denote ISD with a set of all the
independent sets of graph G and so the
counting problem actually asks the size
of this set
okay so here we introduce a kind of a
distribution let's say x is choosing
from this
isg uniform basically X is that
we could pick a line independent set of
graph uniform and random
then
from that actually we can Define the
probability that some vertex V is in a
choosing independent set or not
okay so yeah I used not for some for the
notation simple learning but it's the
same thing
Okay so
for this uh this case of independent set
we all know that the empty set is an
independent set because it contains no
vertex so it's independent and uh so so
what's the problem is that this randomly
choosing X is happening to be the empty
set
on one hand
it should be one over the size of
independent set because each independent
set from the uh from this set is
choosing randomly uniformly so this is
one of the size of the independent
then we can also write this term from
other perspectives so this means that uh
uh all the all the vertices are not
choosing in the in the past cell so this
can be read down as a conditional
marginal probability this is this means
that it's equal to the probability that
the first vertex is not choosing and
given that the first which is not
choosing and the second one is still now
choosing so and so forth this this is a
chain of conditioning probability and
this property X is equal to n plus set
is equal to this product
is just a modified graph by deleting the
previous vertices this is basically uh
indicated as the condition that all the
previous verdicts are not choosing in
the independence
okay so put these two equations together
we get that
one of the size of the independent set
is equal to the product of this property
marginal probability
so give us that if you can compute these
marginal probabilities in the right hand
side or approximate computers like the
estimates these uh probabilities then we
can actually compute or approximately
approximately compute the size of the
independent set okay
so the things the main test task is
actually to compute this marginal
probability
and there are two ways the traditional
way is actually to estimate this
marginal probability by sampling this is
a very beautiful line of research which
actually relate discounting with
sampling and it actually gives a
absolute randomized argument to a plasma
County because it's a this value is
estimated by sampling random sampling
talk about a new uh
approach which actually we we don't do
any random sampling actually
approximately compute this module
probability and deterministically and
which one gives FC tasks for for the
accounting problem
okay okay so uh
to make it more formal I will give a
introduce the formal definition of the
spring system and here's a spin system
and this is actually exactly the almost
exactly the same as the graphomorphism
defined by changing your previous talk
and here one more thing is that we have
the so-called external feed which is
called what's a function which I would
Define this okay so uh this speed system
is a term from the static physics is
describing or some particle system and
the vertex are are the particles of the
system and the H describes the
neighborhood relation of the of the
particles and here the spin States is a
finite number q q could be equal to two
or three years to find it actually let's
pins is up down something like that so
it's all the configuration possible
calculation of us of a spin
signal configuration is basically uh
it's a description of all the spin
States for all the uh particles in the
system basically a mapping from the
vertex to the three states okay there
are two functions which describe the
spin system which is a one is The Edge
function which kind of
uh describes the kind of the local
interaction of two particle and which
will give uh which which takes the input
of the two combination of the particle
the state speed states of the two-party
neighborhood particle and which gives a
real value not negative real value which
somehow indicates the energy of this
interaction another function is a West
function which actually mappings uh the
uh the speedsters of our vertex to a
non-active number which actually
states that if it's this vertex isolate
what is the preference of the spring
States for that for that particle so
the weight of a config of this
particular configuration it takes
summation takes the product over all the
contribution from each Edge and each
vertex
evaluate on this particular spin States
okay since the partition function is
basically the sum of all these fluids
over all the possible configurations
this is the same definition
so for that this basically is always the
country club is the sum of product
explains
so the
probability distribution over this field
is that we actually uh this weight of a
configuration gives less to a published
distribution basically says that the
probabilistic the probability of of the
system being in a particular
configuration is proportional to the
weight
of the uh of this particular
configuration here this uh partition
function actually uh acts as a
normalized fact because this is
estimation of all the possible ways
okay so this definition is which is also
called the Egypt's measure or the chip
or the postman distribution in the
Instax physics and this actually gives
uh joint joint a joint distribution of
all the possible uh particle in the
system and from that from this joint
distribution we actually can Define the
modular distribution of the state on a
particular uh particle or vertex V so
this is defined if we sum of all the
other possible particles
then we can get a marginal probability
for a particular vertex to be one of the
particular speed States
and we can also Define the uh the
conditional marginal probability if some
of the uh vertex have a fixed
configuration so some of the vertex in
the system may be fixed for some reason
then we can talk about the marginal
probability the conditional model
probability of other vertex
looks good
Okay so
I says this speed system is a model in
static physics and also in applied
probabilities this uh this can this can
also be viewed as a flamework or many
communal counting problem I will get
that later and this has many
applications in like in machine learning
including sales and so on
and why this can be viewed as a counting
problem these two example has already
shown the batching in the previous talk
so if this Edge functions like this this
uh this Matrix Matrix is Cellular in the
diagonal and so on
the position function of this uh this
spin system is exactly
the I mean the number of three coloring
overclock
because this this really means that for
the two adjacent uh vertex they are not
allowed to have the same color
and
similarly this big Matrix uh also LED
here previously it's it can be
interpolated as an independent set of
the blood and the partition function
exactly counts the number of solutions
okay
so first this kind of spin systems there
are many tasks shut down otherwise to
compute this marginal probability which
is a very important in the in the
machine learning communities you want to
to do this influence on this graphic
model and we may sometimes it will have
sampling sample configuration Global
configuration with respect to this
Chip's measure okay and other other task
is already mentioned as our essential
task which is compute the partition
functional that all of them actually
kind of related if you can do one of
them efficiently you can do other
efficient in terms of approximate
accounting
okay actually is a
in the applied field actually they have
a very
famous arrogant to do
to compute all this tasks and which is
called the brief provocation
which is also called the message passing
algorithm this is kind of a heuristic
method which is widely used inside
physics machine learning and other many
other applications and
the aircon behaves very well in certain
applications but the problem is that
there's no much electrical justification
for that unless the graph is very
special
if the graph is achieving there's a
seriously that this brief propagation
will compute the right number
so here's a very large high level I high
level description of what the
propagation is it's actually start with
some very kind of arbitrary initial case
of the States of each particle see
you're going to recursively finds a case
based on some local information
basically you define the your your guess
of the states or the or the probability
of certain particle based on the
neighborhood of this particle and you do
that over again and after finite number
of fixed number of intellations you
actually just outputs the the current
state after the the coaching the main
problem with this this holistic
algorithm is that you don't know if this
process will actually converge to a
number
even if it converts we don't know if
it's converged to a collect number not
so that's the main question and
two
for these three steps actually the first
first step is more problematical in some
sense because this case is quite
arbitrary
on the hand you cannot have a really
good good guess if you already have a
good guess you don't really need to do
the coach anyway so in order to prove
kind of converges and collectiveness the
idea is that you want to say that the
final output is almost irrelevant to the
initial guess as long as your performer
uh the the location for long enough
steps that's the idea okay so so initial
case we're not affects the final output
too much as long as you already do that
over again and again for for long enough
steps so this idea is actually captured
by this this notion of correlation
decade which is one of the uh keywords
on my title so let's define this
Collision care for the for the spin
system first so
a speed system of family glove said to
have an exponential quality Decay is
that the marginal probability of a
certain vertex of the particle condition
on uh configuration of another subset
Lambda
is very close to each other if this
Lambda is kind of far away from your
vertex which basically says that the
configuration Which is far for the
vertex Which is far away from you is
have very small influence of your
marginal probability that's the main
idea
okay so here we I call it big collection
okay because there are another different
energy called a stronger notion well
actually uh here we we say that this
Lambda is a subset of vertex which has
fixed configuration and we want this
vertex should be further away from this
set but the two-party configuration
could be have the same stage for certain
works and for different stressful others
other other uh other vertex and if they
have us if we have they have a same
stage then it should be intuitively it
should be okay because in the two
partial calculations you have the same
stage even if it's close to you because
it's the same in the two through uh
conditions that does not affect much so
use a strong correlation Decay it's this
distance is defined from this works V to
only to the subset of Lambda which was a
partial configuration are not the same
okay the distance is distance in the
blood yeah
foreign
definition in the speed system and as I
said this is very related to the the
different location and it's there are
many different ways to interpret this
this property of class Decay one we're
saying that is that this is describes
the significance of long distance
interaction if it's of collecting the
care just kind of the the long distance
interaction is relative is insignificant
also if you view the subset Lambda as
kind of the boundary of the system this
is talking about the effect of a
boundary system a bundle uh conditions
well effects in the for the for the
vertex Which is far from the boundary
and this is not too direct but it's it's
well related to that this this is also
talking about the effect of the initial
case in the brief location
you actually uh Lucas really find your
guess based on your local information so
after like air steps so only the the
information which is within uh the
distance of air can have effect on you
after this
and which the the the information on the
works which is further away where cannot
affect you so only if the system have
this kind of collagen care it's there's
a hope that the brief location algorithm
can work fine and for
for Statics physics is a big question
here is that how to calculate the
systems with this property I could
indicate because a system with with
Collision kind of work without without
collagen care where we have very
differently because
okay actually our main result for the
this part is a globalization of this
property for one family of of spin
system which is two spring system which
is a special family of spin system we
are only have two steps so Q is equal to
two for that there are only a two
bedroom Matrix and a one by two I mean
and for that of it we can do some
normalization because a global fact will
not affect the the this and will not
affect the relative weight and we are
not affects the distribution at all so
we can normalize that of diagonal as
once and two parameters on the for the
edge function and then the one parameter
for the first option so basically a
two-step screen system can be described
as repellent beta gamma land and there's
two similar of this two-state spin
system it depends on this data time
gamma is larger than one or less than
one and I would like to mention that if
beta times uh Lambda is gamma is equal
to one then
in some sense this this system is
degenerate because this this can be
decomposed in into two blank one uh
vector and is that in that case there's
no interaction among the two edge of the
of the
two neighborhood particle and in that
case uh the the physics system is
trigger and the computation problem is
also trivial which is a check one with a
checkable case in the dichotomy Theory
and so when this is a lesson one or less
than one behaves very differently uh
both in terms of physics property and
computation properties so in this this
work will mainly focus on this
anti-final system where this beta time
gamma is lesson one
the two special uh
which is widely studied basically
physician in computer science why is
this hardcore model as I mentioned this
is a basically in the in our world it's
it's computes the the independence it's
a independent set of graph and this is
another
special case called the EC model whereas
the beta is equal to
anti-felamic using that is
to introduced our globalization of of
the closing Decay for this special
system actually we need one definition
which causes uniqueness condition of the
system and I'm not going to the detail
the definition of that basically
so the message here is that if we are
given the parameter beta gaman Lambda
actually we can test you can numerically
at least numerically test this
property
efficiently and but we don't have a
closed form for that
I will talk about this is unique up to
degree something or only something
yeah sorry
okay this is the one one message and
another message basically saying that
this this requirement uh basically
saying that on the fixed point is kind
of a contract mapping which which is uh
easy to show that this is is indeed a
necessary condition for the correlation
Decay on the system which degree
and the characterization was first uh
approved for this special case of
Hardcore model bios actually showing
that this uniqueness is not only a
necessary condition but also a
sufficient condition in the sense that
this strong correlation Decay holds on
all graph is maximum degree Delta if the
uniqueness condition on infinite that
regulatory
close here this condition will
transformed to the pneumatic condition
where this D is equal to Delta minus one
because the location you are
yeah then this is the numeric definition
of the
okay so there's two Integrity of this
proof for the for the colonization one
important construction is that is so
called a self-awarding working shoe
which actually transformed my general
graph to achieve which keeps the
marginal probability of the loot I will
get into that later and the another
integral used is that is kind of a
at least as fast as a complete steel
argument so basically this
uh this technique in enables the rest to
to only prove the Collision Decay
because any graph can be transformed to
a two and this second step solution is
that any two with with the atmos Delta
the case as at least as fast as the
Delta luggage which that lag so the the
Decay on the Delta languages is exactly
the uniqueness
conditions
so here is the the definition of the
self awarding working basically that's
starting from our works V like this with
one and we can expand G this is this
expansion on the two basically
illuminates all the possible simple
parts of the
of the on this graph starting from this
vertex one so this is the one two this
is the one
yeah this is one one three four like one
this this one will be closing the
closing the uh kind of closing the the
loop and so the final one will be
already fixed in some sense I will not
go to another this is a there's a
proceed to to transform a graph uh from
starting from some vertex to a g has a
property that the marginal probability
of this vertex in the graph is exactly
equal to the marginal probability of
this root of the chi
so it's enough to prove the closing
Decay
graph and but the one thing is that in
Thai the size of the cell phone working
sheet could be much larger and it's
actually could be of exponential size
companies it
it's actually enumerate all the possible
simple parts and uh one good thing is
that this this uh construction actually
works not only for the hardcore model
but for all the two-state speed systems
so we will also use that in our blue but
the bad thing is that this only works
for the two-step spin system then you as
better we will further extend that to
multi-speaking system or to I mean
multiple system is no longer work
okay letter uh for the special case of
easy model is also the same same uh
statements was also prove
which actually uh joins that uniqueness
condition is per sufficient and
necessary
because for that they also have the same
monotone
our main
effort to trying to extend this partial
this is calculation for for special uh
system to General Tuesday spin system
and the most difficult part is that the
monotone seed condition no longer holds
for the general
toasted spin system
and so then we need to prove the closing
the care for the generation not only the
the Delta language with which that is
with the maximum degree so
so pullover comes out actually we
finally
showing that this kind of localization
which says that the system is over
correlation Decay on all the glove with
maximum degree data if one only if this
system have this unique disconnection
for all the degree up to Delta so it's
not only for the
and in particular if this this Unix
condition actually holds for all the
degree not there are no constitutional
maximum degree so in this system
actually could have the correlation
Decay property for all the glass so this
kind of things have not been have not
been seen for the special case like a
hardcore model or the easy model because
for this kind of too special uh system
there's no windows degree is large
enough the system is always not okay so
this is kind of a new phenomena for the
general for certain range of the new
general system
and uh
with this kind of localization of the
Collision Decay and the the generals and
standard approach from this marginal
probability to counting and we can have
a kind of evolution implication of our
results that we obtain every stars as
long as the system satisfying the unique
connection to the partition function or
to compute the marginal probability or
to sampling and this a group result is
in some sense tight because there's a
matching kindness result showing that if
the system does not satisfy in your next
condition then it is already NP hard
to approximate the partition functional
system this is
yeah actually the uh for the fire magnet
system is is the final
yet
there is
yeah yeah exactly yeah
but for General truth there's been a
very magnificent
if there's no excellent field then it's
it's always easy and if there's a
external field then literally we prove
that in certain branches could be hard
but the hardness is not amphihis it's
called the best harness is is as hard as
counting the uh uh independent set for
backpack graph which is
hot okay so here I will give a general
idea a high level idea of the whole
proof goes
so uh here is the same same identity I
showed before this uh
basically uh in the in the previous
example we're showing that the empty set
is independent set so we can use that as
a as a bludgeon point to to let the
partition function to the marginal
probability here we can choose a kind of
a some any configuration like all the
other function this can be one in one
hindsight it's not as the weight of the
the configuration time over the
partition function on the other hand it
can be like a product of some marginal
problems so if we can kind of estimate
this module probability then we can
approximately compute this participation
in hand we actually can estimate this
marginal probability by the local
neighborhood basically you can truncate
this self audience working too up to the
logarithmic depths then from the leaf we
can we'll use a dynamic programming we
can compute all the multiple probability
from the leaf to the root then this this
computation will gives a good
approximation for them
yeah he has a standard way but but in
the previous uh result like hardcore and
easy that's good enough because the the
maximum degree of the collapse is
pounding so the the lesson depth is is
over polynomial size and if the foreign
actually we are showing that it's it's
not only uh the kind of the the
Collision the the arrow only not only
the case but constructed but actually
the case as with a super constant fact
and this is the formal definition or we
call this m best uh depths which
actually is the final definition of the
steps and uh we are showing functioning
that the exponential connected care also
holds with respect to this new
definition and with this new definition
actually
this decade will support FC tasks for
any general graph so that's that's one
thing the Muslim part actually how to
prove the quality Care the process since
that if we already have closed in the
care we can have the air conditioning
part so how to prove that closing okay
the idea that will be using yourself for
networking shoe to get the extension and
then uh for the chi as there's no
there's independent food all the sub
shoes and we can write a recursion from
the marginal probability of the root of
the subject to the root of the
definition of
Gene so you want to say that kind of uh
at some depths then in the in the in the
in the bundle of the truncation we
actually have a kind of arbitrary case
of the of the probability so it says
hello there and yeah even showing that
the yellow for each subchi we are we are
actually
induce a yellow for the roots of the chi
and this is the the relation for the
analog that is
function and so if this this Arrow of
the root is bounded by this quantity and
this is the maximum of all the
so if this quantity this ratio is less
than one then we are happy because after
one step of the location the arrow
decreased by constant fact then that's
that's good enough to join the
exponential okay but the thing is that
this partial derivative is a function of
all the valuables p and it's usually not
the case that this quantities which is a
is a function of many variables is
always less than one to all the choice
of this variable as well
is the same and
so which means that this may not be uh
cracked stepwise so saying one new idea
of use is using a protection function to
amortize that the idea is actually quite
simple from a mathematic point of view
you actually introduce the object
function free from uh non-explio To None
basically we
mapping this uh marginal probability P
into a new domain which is called a q
may not have any physical meaning but
just a mapping a mathematic mapping see
this as this is a project function
mapping so this is the location on this
P this F function on on the P actually
induce a location on Q okay
there's a value for some marginal
probabilities and which induces a
quantity of Q and that is projection and
the question of P we have all the
equation for Q
the other idea is that you want showing
that in terms of this Q the arrow
actually decreased by constant fraction
on each step here are the good things
that we have the freedom to choose this
big function
okay and also the difficult is also can
we how can we find this kind of
partition function so that this after
the mapping this new quantity
the analog this new quantity will
decrease by concentration
and I'll put it more mathematical and
since this audience there are many many
as mathematician so this basically says
that cell function uh the kind of
recursive function and the advanced
showing that this this function is
contraction in the sense that the Jacob
metrics on any any Vector is will
decrease the norm by a constant flat and
this may not be true for the for the
function f and we want to find the
projection mapping and so after this
this mapping this becomes uh conscious
and I don't know if there's any
mathematics 2 or series which can be
used to to decide if there are such map
exists or not and the effect of this
mapping actually can be viewed as a
local Lima magical on the space and
basically if I think that there's a map
here on this uh space and you want to
Define some some local linear magical
space such that given a given mapping on
this space become a
uh contracted an IP so I don't know any
any mathematical tools
maybe I should stop here because the
later I will talk about the multi-speing
system and multiply system maybe I will
list some of that uh just like for a
couple of minutes so multi screen system
means that that to mail the valuable
could be not tools larger than two and a
multi-part system so that each consumer
involves more than two variables and the
one obstacles here that the cell phone
works should not work anymore and to
overcome that actually we introduced
more conception notion which called
computational which actually relates the
probability of certain valuable on
certain instances to
enabled in a smaller instance so this
computation is no longer a instance of
the new system only to vertex of the
competency is valuable on a certain
modified instance and which which this
only defines a value which is
the probability so in this this value
can be computed as a recursive function
for some other values
so basically this is a str2 but this is
no longer an instance of the original
system and you can
similarly Define collaboration Decay on
this computation which basically says
that if the chunk it is at certain
depths then the estimation
for this value can be essentially close
to the True Value when
with respect to the steps L and if we
have that we can still have the uh
and I just have a few problems a few
results like this is a one most
canonical multi-speed system which is a
graph coloring problem and here I'll
actually be showing that if if the
number of coloring is larger than this
quantity Where Delta is the maximum
degree of graph then we have a task to
concern about
coloring and general multiple system you
don't really have a conversation but if
you have some sufficient condition if
this is some definition
if they have we have these conditions
then we have ft tasks to compute
data or have exponential
develops and here I uh
multi speed system and now I introduce a
two multi touch assist system so here's
a complete problem which contains the
edge cover of the graph so eight color
graph is a set of edge such that every
vertex has at least one edges at Edge on
it so this is that is
colored glass so for that we want to
come come to number Edge cover
previously this is
known for this based on the sampling
method which is called mcmc and recently
with link and Leo we actually showing
that using the calculation Decay
Technique we can kill FC tasks for
General glass without any decrease
you should use okay okay
foreign
property for all the works that cannot
be done because we need to transform
this to a Serial for any working sheet
so basically I need to compute each
individual marginal probability by a
separator run of the recursion
machine learning algorithms
yeah I think so yeah yeah
let me show this contraction Slide the
contraction
yeah yeah
so isn't it equivalent to say I don't
see how you can modify it by fee to make
it contracted doesn't it mean that the
eigen values are of Norm strictly less
than one
uh yeah that's what it means right
depends on what Norm you choose but yeah
you have only one now there are not
choices it's a complex number
so you take the G of X that's the
Jacobian matrix yes and
you take the eigen values of that
and that should be stick till the
eigenvalues should be Norm less than one
isn't it the condition for contraction
yeah yeah you want to see if you want to
insert percentage
no no it changes
evaluating different points yeah this is
a fear of the F the company yeah it
changes yeah that's what I was thinking
that's right so you're yeah yeah right
so you are composing at different points
yes
okay so that can that can bend so I
think it looks a very natural
mathematical problem yeah
contractions
well developed
Machinery oh really and that's good yeah
so I think something related to this
dynamic system or something like that
yeah yeah but I don't really find that
some some tool which can be used
yeah I think this is a very natural
mathematical problems but it's not going
to be true for all F that's true so I
want calculus yeah yeah some athletes
choose some yeah yeah
right
close the session here thanks